[MUSIC PLAYING]
JACK OLSEN: There's
always this association
between the unicycle
and the circus.
And I couldn't be farther
from being a performer.
I like to pursuit it for sport.
We started trail riding because
once you get the hang of riding
on the road it gets monotonous.
You get on the trail and it's
just so much more satisfying.
ROSS BRADLEY: We're just a bunch
of guys that really enjoyed
mountain it's a very,
very inefficient way
to get around the woods.
JACK OLSEN: You're
working for every inch.
You have to continuously
be aware of every bump
so that you can account for it.
After a while you get
a sense of what rocks
you can actually ride over.
You start pushing that
further and further.
ROSS BRADLEY: So Bryce
is a big strong guy
and rides big strong ways.
It's a big chunk of meat
running down the road.
Jack is amazingly fast,
flies all over the place.
JACK OLSEN: I think
I like to push myself
by committing to speed.
So it can go poorly
very quickly.
But more often than
not it works out.
ROSS BRADLEY: Monty, he actually
hasn't been riding that long.
We called him Superman for a
while because of the way he
would fall, which was all out.
CHAD RAMBERG: I was close
to being on my face.
ROSS BRADLEY: And then me.
I like going random
ways off-road.
I love going down steep things.
I like going through
stuff that doesn't look
like you can ride through it.
BRYCE JACOBSON: It's like the
sound of 10,000 knuckles being
cracked at the same time.
You've got it, Russ.
You've got it buddy.
ROSS BRADLEY: This
is a unicycle.
It's special because
of the size of the tire
and the amount of air
that can be put into that.
Fat tire is nice.
It goes over rocks,
sticks, mud, goo, sand.
The handle is very important.
It helps to anchor your
feet into the petals.
It's got brakes.
These are hydraulic.
So unicycles do not coast.
When you stop pedaling
the wheel stops.
BRYCE JACOBSON: OK, so
mounting a mountain unicycle
you want to make sure that your
pedals are in the right spot.
So you want to give
yourself a pedal
that when you push down on
it pushes the unicycle back
underneath you.
JACK OLSEN: When
I was in college
a group of us all
kind of learned
how to unicycle together.
We did get to the point where
we were riding all over campus.
We'd ride to class.
We got a lot of attention, maybe
not what we were looking for.
ROSS BRADLEY: I could
ride a unicycle since I
was 12, 40 years from today.
I was ridiculed as a kid.
Because kids find different
things to pick on other kids
about.
And I didn't care.
It was my thing.
I go to work on my unicycle.
I work at a federal facility.
And I park it right out front.
Everybody knows who I am.
CHAD RAMBERG: I
learned later in life.
The hardest thing is
10 hours of failure,
of falling on your face
literally for 10 hours.
It's a challenge.
ROSS BRADLEY: On a unicycle
at the very last minute
you might get turned
the wrong direction,
or worse yet your pedal
is not in the right spot.
All of those things
have to come together.
And when they do it's great.
And when they don't you fall.
If you're not falling
you're not doing it right.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHAD RAMBERG: It's a
certain type of person
that tends to ride
a unicycle You've
got to be not afraid to look
stupid and not worry about what
people think of you.
The group that I ride with we
do it just because we love it.
It's the thrill and excitement
of doing something that you
didn't know you could do.
BRYCE JACOBSON: But you
know, once you kind of get
the hang of it it's really
not a whole lot harder
than riding a bike.
NARRATOR: All Points
Project is a part
of Seeker Stories,
a channel that
features short documentaries
from around the globe.
Be sure to watch our video on
Thailand's bicycle revolution.
SUBJECT: I was racing
through traffic.
This car was right
in front of me.
It had a metal cage around it.
My head went right onto
the cage, like bonk.
NARRATOR: New episodes
every Tuesday.
Please subscribe.